みなさん、こんにちは。すみません
、ストリームをすばやく設定しています。
実際に
は、いくつかの
設定が適切に行われていることを確認する必要があります。
スーパーチャットが有効になっている
と思いますええと、すべてが機能していると思い
ますええと、最後の1秒をください。
ここで1つやるのは楽しいかもしれません
し、
私は今、税金を申告しているような忙しい1週間を過ごしました。基本的に
はたくさんのことが起こっている
ので、ちょっと休憩しようとしています。
ええと、少し違う
ことをしているので、
ええと、メガネはドーガンです。多分、私は
これを外す必要
があります。
これが何を意味するのかわかりませんが、
これは
大丈夫に見え
ますが、すべてはバニティホールの
ような高度なものです。
こんなに長い漢字のコンパウンドはあまり良くないので
[音楽]でも
、この時期に
ストリームをやったのは初めてだと
思うので、
こういう人にはいい時期かもしれないと思いました 東海岸では
、おそらく西
ヨーロッパや
アフリカの他の場所の視聴者のように、少し遅すぎるかもしれませんが、
確かにそれは
おそらく
大丈夫だと思います。日本のほとんどの人は
おそらく今見ていません。
早朝
に学校に子供を降ろしたばかりですが、
ここに来たことのない新しい人をここに迎えることができれば
と思います。実際に
は、眼鏡が見えないので、眼鏡をかけ直し
ます。 チャットだ
から私は
いくつかの質問に
答えようと思った youtubeで1つ
やった liはヤバドンでやった
けど
、その外で
少しだけツイッチでやったんだけど
、やったほうがいいと思った
[音楽]
サウスダコタのハロードーガンちょっとええと
ペプシ ペプシ
とええと、ポーキーファンの1人に感謝します。
スーパーチャットもありがたいです。
うーん
[音楽]
だから
、ヨーロッパから本当に有名な作家がたくさん
います
。
彼がソトシウを作った
ドゲンという名前の日本の僧侶を
知っていますか？はい、彼が寺院を作ったのを知っています、
そしてそれは私が私の名前を得た
場所
です あなたの名前には
漢字が書かれて
いますか？ええ、ここに書いてみます
か？サインインできますか
？ ここで
クールな
インドすごい面白いインドだけでなく、
完全に似ているよう
なものです 異なる文化ですが、それでも
非常に
特に近年非常に非常に非常に非常に非常に非常に非常に非常に非常
にインドでは開発の速度が完全に狂っています
特に私
は2040年
までに2030年だったかもしれないと言った少し前の記事を読みました。
インドのGDPは
2050年だったかもしれません。日本
より高いはずだっ
たのかわからないので、卒業後はとても面白いと思います。
今日は宿題を終えたときのようなニュアンスのようなものです。
日本に引っ越してニホンに引っ越す予定なので、
一度学校を卒業したら、卒業したらいいと言ったほうが
いいでしょう。 そこに着いた配達サービ[ __ ]
ありがとうボイル
このええとキキの配達サービスは
おそらく私のお気に入りの
umghibli映画で
あり、おそらく2位は
元気づけられていますああキキの配達サービスはおそらくとは言えません
ドーゲン
ええ、ドーゲンええと、その
ギャングはもう二度とあり
ませんええ、それは
私の名前の正しい漢字ではありません私の本名ではありません
私はあなたが何を言おうとしているのか完全にはわかりませ
ん
でも確かに1日5時間以上勉強しているのは確かに元気です。
とても印象的です。
最近日本語を勉強し始め
ました。たくさんの
日本語があります。 チャイナ
日本人はあなたの経験からチャイナについてどのように感じているかをどのように学び
ますかええと、それは本当に
すべて
個人に依存し
ます
あなたが出会った日本人
は、中国に
関連するほとんどのことに関して、古い世代は少し躊躇していると言われて
いますが、新しい
世代は
あなたが使っているものを使っている世代が多いと思います 今
、特にソーシャルメディアは
、中国に関連するものに関しては、はるかにオープンで
フレンドリーだと思います。明らかに、私は
明らかに、中国の政権が好きではないことを知ってい
ます
が、私はたくさんの
中国のすべての起業家を尊重します。
特に中国の人々は
本当に一生懸命働いている
ようです。私たちはかなりの量のように私たちが州に戻っていることを知っ
ている
ので、ちょっと犬と私は高低
アクセントに興味があります。
アップルの辞書のようなオンラインリソースを見つけることができ
ます
か？各単語がどのパターンを使用しているかを教えてくれますスズキカンをグーグルで検索すると、スズキと呼ばれるリソースを検索し
そうでなければ
[音楽]
それは本当にあなたの個人的な状況に依存します
が、私の一般的なアドバイスは
、
日本で幸せな生活を送るための鍵は、おそらく長期的にはほとんどの場所で、
一生懸命働くことを決してやめないことだと思います。  o凝視カード
をできる
だけ使用しないでください。なぜなら、geysingカードを使用
すればするほど、無意識のうちに
、あなたとあなたの周りの普通の日本人のように、あなたの間に障壁を築くことができると
思います。
多くの状況でこのような安価な方法を使用する
ことは、ほとんどの状況
で
、より高度な日本の知識や日本文化の知識などを必要とするより難しいことを行う方が長期的には良いと思います
それは確か
に短期的には難しいことですが、
長期的には
、そのような
小さな努力
は、長期的または長期的に支払われることがよくあり
ます。
なぜアメリカ人は日本をよく考えるのですか？
私は日本が好きです
私は日本が大好きです
[音楽]
まるで真夜中か早朝のように感じ
ます。
アレンゲ
あなたが言っているので、夜は
そうですね、これは420に基づいた冗談だと思います。
それから漢字も
実際のフレーズかもしれ
ませんが、私はそれを知りませんが、私はしません
とても
日本語のフレーズだと
は思いませんが、日本語の学習者として最初に学ぶことの1つですが、
めったに使用しません。
[音楽]
私のお気に入りのクラシック音楽家は、おそらく私のお気に入りで
はないでしょう。
クラシック音楽家はショパンなので、
私はいつも
プロキシではなく
ポーランドに興味を持っていました。あなたのビデオについて
非常に批判的で系統だったように見える人が
混沌としたライブストリーム
環境であるため、ポーランドに興味があります。 または
疲れるええと、すみません、最初に他の質問に答えなければなり
ませんええと、ジャコビーええと
、スーパーチャットに感謝します。
日本語を書く
と、明らかに時間をかけることができますが
、日本語
を話すと、ネイティブのスピードに
慣れていないことがよくあり
ます。 勉強を重ねるうち
に、
母国語で
も
そうなることがわかります。圧倒的多数の場合、私と同じように
話せるレベルより上のレベルで、上にある言語を理解
できるということです。
ハーバードの教授が高度なトピックについて話していることを知っているように理解でき
ますが、ii
は彼らほど明確に話すことができないか、彼らほどスムーズに話すことができません。
それは
、私が彼らほど頭が良くないからです
が、日本人にも同じことが言えます。
日本語を勉強して
いると
、
最初は少なくともそれらの
フレーズ
をスピーチで再現して文法をまとめる
ことができなくても、人々が言っていることをたくさん理解することができます
。 非常に批判的に見える人
として[音楽]を話す
特にストリームの前半でこれについて言及したので
、今
はアメリカの税金などに取り組んで
いるので
、書類のようなものが
たくさんあり、スプレッドシートでたくさんのことをするのと同じです
最近
こういうことをやっているので、
もう少しソーシャルでダイナミックなことをやると、
確かにさわやかです。
[音楽]
それは本当にあなたの
性格や状況
に依存します。 毎日学校に通うカリキュラムのようなものがあるので
、日本の学校で上手くやっている人のかなりの数
は、同じことをしているのと同じではあり
ませんが、彼らは
彼らのために、そして本当にうまくいく人たちのためにレイアウトされた道があります
が、私のような他の人たちが
含まれ、明らかに
マット対日本が好きで、最近ツイッターで
共有した人の一
人は驚異的な日本語を持っている
と思い
ます 他のタイプの人
は自分で勉強するほう
がいいですし、
ある種のイマージョンアプローチに従うと、
そのようにたくさんのネイティブ日本語
を聞くこともまた別のアプローチ
です。
できるだけ高いレベルに到達すること
に興味があるなら、それはおそらく長期的にはより良いアプローチです。
そうですね、gomezというフレーズはどうですか。
これ
はスーパーチャットのおかげのように聞こえます。 繰り返しになりますが、
私はこれがトロールの投稿の
ようなものであるように感じ
ますまたはまたはまたはそれらは
スーパーエゴメスの
ようなものです
漢字を言うのは難しい私は個人的に漢字
を学ぶための最良の方法は漢字では
なく
個々のカード
または個々の単語にフラッシュカードを使用することだと
思います 浸透によって
漢字の意味
を学び始めると、明示的に学ぶ
ことなく、それぞれの
漢字の意味を理解し始める
ので、最高の漢字
のよう
に漢字を学び、最悪の漢字を学ぶ場合のように
それからあなたは無意識の
うちにその最初の漢字が
この最上級であること
を学びました
その漢字が含まれているコンワードを勉強して、その個々の
漢字を明示的に勉強しないと
、時間の経過とともにそれを拾い始めます。
私は
日本語の授業で宿題の
ように基本から中級のようなより基本的なレベルのような
もので漢字を個別に勉強したことはありませんでしたが、高度な漢字のように私はそれらを個別に勉強したことはありません私は
いつもそれらを勉強しました
個々の言葉の中で
すごいええと50アルゼンチン
からのええとホラありがとうございます
私を日本語にもっと慣れさせてくれてありがとう
そして今私は毎日それを学び
ました私の喜びええと私はアルゼンチンについてたくさんの良いことを聞いたの
です 私はすべての国についてこれを言って
いますが
、私の世代から人気のある本の1つは、
ティモシーフェリスによる週4時間の仕事と呼ばれるこの本
だと思います。
コロナは人気がありませんが、コロナには
必要です。彼は
さまざまな場所から旅行して仕事をする
ことを
勧めました。  mはアルゼンチンで、
一番の都市は
ブエノスエアレスでした。それを読ん
で以来、私はいつもああのようでした。あまり詳しく説明されていないので、なぜいわばそう
なのかを見てみたいと思います。
mマンダリンへの露出についてはよく
わかりませんが、
とても寛大な寄付を
ありがとうございました50ありがとうございます。
日本語の勉強を
頑張ってくださいマンダリンへの露出についてはよく
わかりませんが、学ぶのはもっともらしいと思います
か 日本語と一緒に文字を混同せずに
そうです文字を混同せずにそれを学ぶのはもっともらしいと思います
が、私は文字を
具体的に見て
います。 両方の言語で
それをやろうとすると、書くだけでなく言語の要素
私はそれが
おそらく最も効果的なことではないと思います
読める漢字がかなりあるので
、日本語を勉強してきたからといって読める漢字や漢字を知って
いるので、ある種の漢字があると
思います。 オーバー
ラップは確かにある程度のオーバーラップ
が
ありますが、ええと、長期的には日本語で
行うのがおそらく最も効果的なことではないと思い
ます。
小さいレベルはここでは大丈夫に見え
ますが、障害物に遭遇したときに最初に開始するときに自信を構築するためのヒントはありますか？それは
私のドライブを収縮させるだけ
です。
勉強を続けたくないという状況で、
あなたよりも日本語が上手な外国人を探しましょう。
最近ツイッターで紹介した人のように、
ニックネームでツイッターに行って、
彼の日本語のビデオをチェックしてください。 私
驚異的なのは
確かに私のものよりも優れている彼は音楽業界に興味を持っている
彼はさまざまな職業を
持っている
私も日本人のようにステップアップしたい
ので、モチベーション
を上げるライバルのように作れるなら、あなたよりも日本人の方がいい外国人を見ていると思います。
だからあなたは日本で外国人についてのビデオを作っています
日本に
関連するビデオ大丈夫私は
少しumであなたのチャンネルをチェックしようとします
が寄付をありがとうございましたそして
アルフレッドとローズバッドumもありがとう
[音楽]
外国人
ええと
[音楽]
ああ
外国
人外国人
機械のような機能
かあなたが知っている何かそれを調べて、
私が正しく言っていることを確認させてください
ええ、私はそう思います 大阪で
キノと言えば 昨日という意味なので
、
[音楽]
は本当に寿司屋に住んでいるのかというアクセントがたくさんあるということです。
アマゾンで買ったばかり
です。舌の配置などの正しい発音を学ぶためのヒントです。
私の発音シリーズのpatreonpatreon.comdoganに広く掲載されてい
ます。
ビデオに興味がある場合は、本の代わりに本が好きな場合
は、日本語の音で良い本がたくさんあります。 ヴァンス
はこれ
より日本語が読めるのならいい
本ですこれは
特に舌の配置にとても良い本です
そしてまたこの本の日本語
はかなり
難しいので
あなたが持っていなく
ても
nhkアクセント辞書や新めかいにんごのように読めなくても読めるように、日本語をとてもよく理解している
ので、これらは外であなたに役立つ2つの
潜在的なリソースかもしれません
私のシリーズ
ええと、ええと、日本人を見てみましょう。
申し訳ありませんが、あなたの質問の最初の部分を見逃したと思い
ます。
長い間見ていました
が、
ついにファイナルファンタジー7を打ち
負かしました。ハードモードでリメイクするので、それをプレイする代わりに、
エアロバイクでエクササイズをするときは
、
柔術のことを見て
、 会話のような文章で
、それは驚異的です。とても良い
です。小さな線
のようなものがたくさんあるので、本当に驚きました。作家として、私はまるで私のようです。
良い例のような良いラインは、ええと
[音楽]
のような
ものです。ネタバレをするキャラクターがいます。
早い段階で殺されるキャラクターがいますが、彼は殺される
前に主人公と友達になり
、彼の友達は彼の友達です。 お母さん
も殺されます
がお母さん 彼女が書く前に、
私はまるで私の神のよう
でした。それは書くような良い会話だったので、私は本当にそのようなものに感銘を受けました。
特に柔術の会話に本当に感動しました
。2つのスーパーチャットがありました。
こんにちは、
あなたがかつてオレンジの短編本について話していたオレンジの短編本の名前は何
ですか。 それがあなたが話していることだと思います
金原ひとみええと
素晴らしい話スペイン語の素晴らしい素晴らしい本
私たちの母音が私たちの母音をアーケードするので私たちの音は
ほとんど同じです
私たちの中で安いのは悪い経済です
ええスペイン語スペイン語の母音
は本質
的に日本の母音と同じなので、
発音だけで
はピッチアクセントではなく
スペイン語の発音です は日本人と非常によく似ており、
ほとんどのスペイン人学習者は通常、
最初から本当に良い日本語の発音を持って
います。90年代の最高のアニメです。
私のお気に入りのアニメ
はまだモンスター
であり、言いたいと思います。
2000年代初頭のように
アニメが出てきたのは90年代後半だったかもしれません。
ましろのおと
を見ていたのですが
、シャミセンのプレイヤーについての素晴らしい音楽アニメです。
[音楽]
スーパーチャット
メアリー
と
日本語勉強で
頑張っ
てくれてありがとう
日本人はこの点に到達しました
どのように
よく勉強しましたか私は
多くの異なる種類のスタイルで本当に本当に一生懸命勉強しました
私はたくさんのイマージョンをしました
私はたくさんのフラッシュカードをしました
それ
以外は何よりもまあまあですが
、確かに私を大いに助けてくれた1つのことと
、このビデオの前半で
話した男のニックは、彼のビデオでもこれについて話しましたが、
日本語
を話す自分を録音することは、
あなたが気づかなかったあなたの日本語の小さなことを拾うことでたくさんの
間違いがあったので
、私がこのストリームをして
日本語を話す
とき、私が試みる途中で私が犯すいくつかの間違いがあります
話しているうちに直しますが、それ以上に気付かない
発音のようなものがありますが
、ビデオを
もう一度見ると気付くので
、自分の日本語の声をもう一度見たり聞いたりすることには確かにメリットがあります
日本語を話すときのあなたの声え
えと
、私の友人の1人が
、ストリームが2秒間ダウンしたと言ったところです。
ええと、1つええと
、メキシコからの多くの愛は、
そこで市民権を取得
するのは難しいですはい、ここで市民権を取得するのは非常に
難しいです。 日本よりも
、ええと、日本で市民権を取得することは
、英語の教育の仕事やスペインの
教育の仕事などと言えば、ドアに足を踏み入れることよりもはるかに難しいことではあり
ません。 ドアに足を踏み入れてくださいドアに
足を踏み入れ
てくださいええと、あなたを待っている機会がたくさんあるので、
市民権自体は非常に
難しいですが
、日本に住んで市民権を取得せずに幸せになる方法は他にもあります
。
実際にそれを取得することを考えています
ニュージーランド
[音楽]
新しいジャージ
ええと、おそらく私がお勧めする一番のことは、
アマゾンを開いてマヨナを入力するだけなら、2つあると言ってください。
ise inJapaneseそしてそれからマヨネーズと
呼ばれる日本語の電子本があるはずです
そしてそれは私が書いた短編小説の1つですそしてそれは
おそらく
私が書いた中で最高の短編小説だと思いますそれは
おそらく若者の物語の到来のようなものです
何よりも、それ
はコメディ
のようなものでもあり、全体が言葉の大きな遊びのようなものです。それは
私がお勧めするもの
ですが、寄付とパトレオンに慣れていないあなたの文章の幸運に感謝します
ので、ここに
いくつかあります スーパーチャットマネー
ありがとござますええ、
パトレオンが嫌いな人が多いので、数年前に起こっ
た政治的なことと関係があるのではないかと思い
ますので、個人の好みを知って
いる
ので、よろしくお願いします。
ここでの
寄付に感謝します。もう50の寄付があります。
メキシコではクレイジーです。市民権を取得するのは非常に簡単
です。
あなた
が北側に行き着き、たくさんの
ええと、おもしろいああ
、私の妻は料理が上手で、彼女
はキラーを作っ
てくれますが、メキシコ料理が恋しいです。
マヨネーズの住宅所有者に何を聞いて
いるのかよくわからないので、申し訳ありませ
んが、2種類のお気に入りの曲
があります。
グライムスによる忘却そしておそらく
私のもう一つのお気に入りの曲は東京ジハンのケショナオシと呼ばれている
ので
おそらく私の2つのお気に入りの曲は
グライムスが大好きです
japan東京に住んでいたときは少し知っていました
が、今は大田で何も知りません
[音楽]
ええと
、日本のエチケットのヒントはありますか？
ええと、ありがとうございます ちなみに
uperchatええと、私はあなた
が人々のつま先を踏まないことを意識し
、またあなたが日本に
いるときに比較的静かにしようとすると大声で話さないことを意識
している
と思います それはおそらく
私が人々に与えることができる最高の種類の一般的なアドバイスですumgrimesslapsbruh
彼女は叙事詩ですええええ
東京ジハンえ
えと
Park
umうまくいけば、私
は将来もそのyoutuberであり続ける
ことができます。また、ジェットプログラムには年を取りすぎ
ていて、エンジニアリングの仕事に十分な言語に堪能でない
人でも、外国人にとって他にどのような機会
を探すことをお勧めしますか。 ジェットプログラムでは
若い人を好むのではないかと思います
が、東京
オリエンテーションで出会った人の方
がずっと年上でした。 ハン私だ
から年齢制限はないと思い
ますが、若い人を好む傾向がありますえ
えと、あなたのスキルセットが
わからないので言うのは難しい
ですが
、私が与えたい一般的な
アドバイス 日本で働きたい人は、英語の会話学校の
ように、学校のように英語を教えるような言語でドアに足を踏み入れ、
あなたがやりたいことを
見つけて、修正が必要なスキルに取り組むことです。
もしあなたが日本でエンジニアリングをしたい
のにあなたの言語がまだそこにないなら
あなたの日本語はまだあなたの日本語に取り組んでいません
あなたが日本語であなたのために
エンジニアリングが実行可能になる
までそれはクレイジーに聞こえますがたくさんあります
ええと、
あなたは日本語で夢を見ますかええ、
私は日本語でかなりの量を夢見ています私は
ほとんどの人が日本語を勉強していると思います外国
語は
彼らが勉強している言語で夢を持っている
と思います
おもしろいの
は、思い出
が日本語に変わり始めたときだと思うので
、家族のように
日本語が話せない、友達
のように高いところからの思い出がたくさんあります。 学校と
中学校の
流れの都市のチュートリアルのように、スパムをやめて
くださいええ、スパムをしないでください
、しかしあなたが面白いことは
、あなたが言語で特定のレベルに到達し始めるとき、あなた
は記憶ではない記憶を持ち始めることです
もともとその言語ではなかったあなたが勉強している言語
がその言語になるので
、英語しか話せず、日本語が話せない親友のよう
な思い出
がたくさんあります。 私にとっては
、それはかなり面白いと思います。
夢の中で日本語を話すときは、マット対日本ねえ
、ピッチの事故が正しいかどうかいつも心配している
ので、マット対日本は、ええと、私を知らない人のために
いくつかのビデオをやりました 彼と一緒です
が、彼は少なくとも私と同じ
くらい日本語が上手で、私
よりも上手に仕事をしています。私
は物事の発音の面に集中していますが、
マットは長期的な全体論的アプローチのようなものについては本当に良いです
日本語をできるだけ上手に使いたい人のための学習パス
なので、
マット対日本の
コンテンツを
強くお勧めします。彼は素晴らしい人でもあり
、私が困難な状況にあるときに助けてくれた
ので
、叫び声を上げてくれてありがとう マットに立ち寄ってくれ
てありがとうもちろんここに来てくれてうれしい
ですこれで見てみましょうこの税
控除は私がこのチャットから得た収入に課税さ
れるものです
モーニングドーガンそれはええと845
ここでおはよう
マット対日本は私の宿敵です彼は
私に学ぶように動機づけますええ彼は
私が言ったように私にも学ぶ
ように動機づけ
ます
umiで停止するため しばらく連絡を取りたいので、今のように連絡を取りたいです。
ソーダチャットにメールアドレスを書いて
、学士号を取得してメールを送ってください。
ライブスタディを動かしてここで働く方法として日本で学士号を取得している日本は、
特に前のビデオで話したように
、日本人学生と同じ授業料を払っている留学生が
apuのような場所に行くため、犯罪的に過小評価さ
れています
長期的に日本に入国しようとしているなら、実際にドアに足を踏み入れるのに本当に良い方法です。
なぜなら、ドアに足を踏み入れて、
いわばソラと言えば、長期的に自分自身を準備するからです。
私はあなたがここにいることをとてもうれしく思います
私は最近あなたのビデオをたくさん見
ましたええと日本の人々が座っていると言うとき
私はそれがとても良いビデオ
ですそれは
とても良いビデオ
です
私はあなたの仲間だけだと思います
一般的に私はそれが本当に好きな
ので、
多分私はあなたがここにあなたのチャットを書くことができないかもしれないのか分からないかもしれません。
私は
少しの間あなたのツイッターを探して
いましたが、これはフリーズしました
ああ私は私たちのために2番目のチャットをしました
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
ええと、ツイッターはありません。
韓国語を学んだ後、最近日本語を学び始めまし
た。文法と語彙
が他の言語で試してみる計画がどれほど似ているかにショックを受けました。
他の言語を
学ぶほど、私は知っていると思います。
日本語に加えて、
私の日本語は悪化し、
私は私の日本語ができる限り上手になる必要
がありますええええええ、ツイッターはゴミです
ええそれはあなたがどのように使うかによります
ツイッターのように私は
決してチェックしません
私がフォローしている人のほかにツイッターでngし
て、
それをやったら、ツイッターは
本当に本当に楽しいと
思います。お互いを追加して不和にすることもでき
ます。
あなたはまだ酔っ払っています
[音楽]
私はいつも日本語を学び始める方法を考えていましたここシンガポール
には有名な
語学学校がありますが
、私はそれをすべて忘れたので、私は再学習したいのですが、登録するか自己学習する
べきか疑問に思いました
マットvsジャパン
リフォールドドット
彼のサイトリフォールドをチェックしに行きます長期
的に日本語を学び
、マットのアプローチを可能な限り高いレベルに到達することに興味があるなら、
私は本当に本当にそうだと思い
ます
いいですね、日本語の発音を学ぶことに興味があるなら
、私は私のパトレオンでそれを教えてい
ます。 で話しました
私たちが一緒に行ったビデオの1つは、
2、3か月のような最初のような語学学校の
ように、ある種の基本
を理解するために行くことは非常に有益である可能性があるということです。 確か
にあなたが言ったように、どこから始めれば
いいのかわからない人がたくさんいるので
、どこから始めればいいのか、
ちょっと
圧倒されるかもしれません
が、もしあなたが少し好きなら
構造化されたコースのように、明らかに
数学のコースも構造化されて
いますが
、少なくとも最初の1か月か2か月の間、
宿題などを強制する教師のような人がいる場合、それは確か
に一部の人々にとって有益です。
でも長期的には、
マットのアプローチはおそらく最高の
リフォールドだと思います。残念ながら、
ドットコムドメインは非常に高価でした。
特に
日本語が話せる
なら、曲の構成や
メロディー
、作曲自体は
すごい
けど、それがボサノバの曲のようで、
それはまた、
学生で
はなく、別れの歌ではなく、学生が壊れているようなものです。
ハートブレイクソング
のように別れたり誰かがいなくなったりするような曲な
ので、この曲は
おそらく私の2つのお気に入りの曲の1つです
が
、ボサノバのような幸せな明るい曲のような二分法
です。 そして、歌詞のように、悲しいことで
はないようなスーパーのような歌詞
は、とにかくサビのような正しい言葉ではありません。
ジェット以外に1、2年日本に住む方法についてのアイデアを学んだ
私は日本に住むのが大好きですが、
私は教えることで売られていません私は
あなたが十分に若いならそれはbかもしれません
apuのような日本の学校に行くの
はオプションかもしれません
が、あなたが年上で
すでに大学に通っているなら、
先に言ったように、私は実際
にドアに足を
踏み入れるだけでエイカイワのようなことをしていると思い
ます たくさん働く必要はない
かもしれませんが、1日5時間かわからないようなものかもしれませんが
、仕事によっては、その仕事をすることができれ
ば、理解するのに十分な時間があります。
あなたが自由な時間に何をしたいのか、
そして/またはあなたの本当の情熱をするために何をするのに必要なスキルセットを開発する
ので、それは
私が
ドアに足を
踏み入れるために私がお勧めするものです
1つは
けいれんのためですが、
それは私が持っている唯一のものなので、それは
あなたがドーガンの不和サーバーであるかのようなものですが、
クレイジーな別の50の寄付に
感謝し
ます
ええと、私はええメランチョと言うでしょう licは
おそらく
それのための最良の言葉
ですええと、あなたがドーゲン不和サーバーが欲しい
なら、おそらく
ええ、twitch.com twitch.tvに行き
、そしてそこにそのサーバーへのリンクがあり
ます [音楽]
が痛くなり始めました
。
リツイートもし
ます。おそらくもう1時間ほどストリーミングする
ので、今日は少し
時間が残って
いるので、ツイートを実際にリツイートします。
誰か
がツイッターに飛び込んできたら、それを見ることができます。
ええと、3ドルありがとうございます
。50ドルではありません。5
ドル
です。どちらにしても、どうもありがとうございました。
[音楽]
大丈夫
英語の先生「ああ、
これをコピーしてくれ
ませんか」と言ったら、これをコピーしてくれません
か。そこに発音を入れる
必要があり
ますが、日本語のように、
誰かと話している場合は、 の
ための言葉にもかかわらず、あなたが言っていることをすぐに理解します あなたは
そこにいないので
、文脈に応じて言うのはちょっと失礼ですええと、結婚した後
のようにそれを使用するようなカップルが
たくさんいるよう
ですが、それはあなたが通常使用するものではありません
友達のように会話をして
いると、
親しい友人のように大丈夫です。親しい友人
と
の多くの状況ではもっと自然かもしれませ
んが、そのような言葉には注意する必要があります。
友達同士の会話のように使われているような言葉を聞いて
、どんな状況でも使えると思って
、
ガールフレンドのお母さんみたいに言って、そういう言葉を聞いてしまう
みたいに
非常に失礼な
ことなので、そうですね
[音楽]
[音楽
]toi確かに連絡します。ずっと
やりたかったコラボができます。また
立ち寄ってくれてありがとう。
ええと、うんちは
大丈夫ですええと、ホーリーkナイトドッグソング
はありませんでした
[音楽]
ジェットインタラクション以外のプログラムを知っていますか？
すでにたくさんの教育経験があるなら
、日本のインターナショナルスクールに申し込むのは有益かもしれません。
東京のインターナショナルスクールを調べて
ください。たくさんの教育
経験があるなら、あなたはできるかもしれません。
給料がはるかに高い場所で就職できる可能性があり
ます。教えることを楽しんでいる場合は、おそらく
もっとやりがいのある経験になる
でしょう。会話するための言語交換アプリのヒントはありますか。
日本人私
は少し前にやってみましたが、今日の映画の話が好きなら
、話したいことを決められれば、ある程度のレベルで日本語が
話せれば、最初の会話を通過することはめったにありません。  w私たちが好きな音楽について話します。
また、別の日の
ように、将来住みたい場所などについて話
します。具体的なことを話したい場合は
、おそらくそれがより良い方法です。 ただのように
会話するのではなく、会話
を進めるために、それはおそらく
、あなたがすでにその会話をたくさんしているのであれば、勉強
するのにそれほど良くないでしょう。
ブライアンありがとうございます。
[音楽]
言語交換アプリのヒントはありますか。
ブライアン、スキットが大好きです。
スーパーチャットをありがとうございます。あなた
は私にとって本当にインスピレーションを与えて
くれました。 日本語を勉強している
ので、いつか
基本的な会話が
よく
わかるといいなと思います。 イマージョンベース
のアプローチのようなマットのアプローチの
ように低く、あなたは
本当に
できるだけ多くの日本人に耳を
傾け
ます。実際に
私が独立したゲーム開発者だと思うよりも早くそのポイントに到達するでしょう。
チャンスや方法があると思いますか
私が日本に引っ越すために、それは私のもので
あり、私の妻の夢
です。私は希望がありますが、本当の
ことではありません。
ええと、週に数時間のようにスペイン語を教えることができます。
たぶん
、できるだけ教えない
仕事を見つけたり、ゲーム開発を開発している
別のゲームで働いたり
する
ことができます。 そのスキルセットも
同様
に、ゲーム
開発を行い、
最終的にはそれ
をフルタイムのプライベートな
職業に変えることができる
かも
しれません。
gettin ここで暑いです
少し大きいかもしれませんが
、ここでは本当に暑くなっ
ています。勉強を始めたときから色が似合っているので、これを外し
たくありません。 日本語を話し始めるに
は、基本的なレベルで話すことができるようになるまでに少し時間が
かかります
か？これはマットのような人をとるアプローチに本当に依存します、そして私は実際に
あなたが長期的にそれにいるならこれがおそらくより良いアプローチだと思います ええと、
実際
に
は、意図的
に言語を話さず
、1
年目などのように絶えず聞いているだけで
、多くの入力を取得して
、話し始める前にそれを感じ始める
ということがあります。 繰り返し
ますが、あなたが取っている言語
哲学または
学習哲学は、
あなたが使用している
ことを何と言いますか
？まったく同時に日本語を話し始めようとすると、それは議論の余地があります。
日本語を勉強し始めると、悪い習慣を身につける可能性が高くなります。
その
議論には、モビックの推論のラインが
10ドルありがとうございます。
毎日週末に2時間ほど学ん
でいます。
週に3回、先生に
語彙についてもっと知ってもらい
ます。これは良いリズムだと思います。
かなりのように聞こえる速いミディアムを行ってい
ます。通常のペースよりも速い
と思いますが、
常に日本語の映画をバックグラウンドで流している場合は、常に日本語を聞いてください。これは、日本語学習
を加速するためのさらに優れた方法です。そうして
、先生と会うと、
一緒に過ごす時間が増えます。
あなたの先生は
あなたが得るよりはるかに価値がありますあなたはあなたがあなたの先生とその間に活用できる
より多くの知識を持っているのであなたはより多くのことを成し遂げる
ことができるでしょ
う n
新しいエントリに新しいビザが与えられる可能性は
主に仕事用ビザ
です今年は新しいビザが発行される可能性は何ですか残念ながら私は
そのことを知り
ませんええと、
もう一度言うことがあるまでおそらく難しいだろうと思います 英語では
、コロナウイルスに対する免疫の集団免疫を聞い
たが、
比較的話すと、
ここの人々は非常に注意深く
、常にマスクを着用しているので
、コロナウイルスを取得する人々の数は、おそらくしばらくは起こらないようです。
まず
、一般の人々
と比較して国の大きさ、そして
アメリカのような場所と比較して
非常に低く、それに加えて、
ここでの予防接種率も非常に低い
ので、潜在的に前の年のように長くなる可能性があります
集団免疫についてもう一度言い
ますが、それが正しい
言葉であるかどうかは思い出せませんが
、少なくとも次の6か月でそれが起こるとは思わない
残念ながら、こんにちはdogenええと、学位が不可欠だと思いますか？
仕事の経験は
、キャリアを探す際にそれを置き換えることができます
私は
それが誰であったか思い出せない
と思います私は大学の学位を持っていない別のyoutuberを知っていたと思います
彼らのチャンネルは本当に大きかったので、youtuberとして直接日本に来
ました。
十分な数の聴衆がいる場合、またはあなたが
元教師である場合、あなたのスキルセットが十分に求められている場合は、
学位を取得しなくても、おそらく日本に入ることができる特定のことは
、圧倒的な少数のケースです。
[音楽]
ええと、日本で英語の先生になるために勉強することは
悪い目標です。
英語を教えることは
、日本で教えることと同じように日本国外で英語を教えることも幸せです。日本で
英語を教えることは良い目標
です。
アルゼンチンで英語を
教え
てもらえると思います。とにかく、英語を教えるのが好きで、どこでも
英語を教えて幸せなら
、日本で英語を教えるのは良い考え
ですが、
日本で英語を教えることを考えている理由は、
アニメや日本文化
など
が好きで、日本語が一歩下がっ
て、残りの部分で実際に何をしたいのかを考えて、日本に住みたいからです。
仕事のための生活は
、日本でそれを試してみて
、キッチンなしで日本でビーガンになっ
ていることを考えてみてください。素晴らしいコンテンツのためのアドバイスはありますか？
私は本当のビーガンではありませんii魚を食べます
が、それ以外は私です 基本的にはビーガンな
ので、用語はプリスクリタリアンだと思う
ので、しばらく肉を持って
いなかったのですが、田舎のような就任式のように
難しいですが、おそらくそれほど難しいとは思いません
東京はちょっと高い
ので知っておくといいのですが、
ビーガニズムは
どんどん人気が出てきています。
日本では毎年、
外国人の英語の先生がたくさんいるアジアの町から来ました。
教えることや英語に
情熱を注ぐ人はほとんどいないので、子供たちの教育が苦しんでいるのを見る
のは悲痛です。
あなたは
可能な限り最善の仕事をすることを知っていますが、
iiはあなたが言うより
受動的
なアプローチを取りましたそして私は
基本的に
私が一緒に働いた日本の教師に
基本的にすべてを決定
させ、おそらくより積極的な
教師になるようにしました ええと、レッスンでもっとイニシアチブを取る
ことは、私がいつも生徒たちと一緒にやってみたと言った生徒たちにとっては良い考えだったでしょう。
本当に英語に情熱を持っていたので、できる限り彼らを助けようとした
ので
、日本語
を話すことはあなたが英語を話す方法に流暢に影響を与えまし
た。 最初に日本語が頭に浮かびますが、
実際
に東京に住ん
でいて、バンドを見つけることができるかのように必要なスキルを持っている限り、ミュージシャンとして生きている西洋人はかなりいます。
それは
、おそらく最高のメンバーとしてあなたを連れて行く
でしょう。彼らは確かに
、posに住んで
いるかなりの数のミュージシャンが
いる可能性があります。 東京に住んで
いるええ申し訳ありませんが
いつも日本語で間違いを犯し
ます申し訳ありません
[音楽]
ええピッチ対ストレスピッチアクセント
言語対ストレスアクセント言語
コンポーネントええと
[音楽]
ええと
外国
えええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
地震や津波で知られる日本のフィットネス業界でのウェイトリフティングの良い仕事は
難しいかもしれませんああ、フィットネス業界は難しいかもしれませんが
、
外国人のフィットネスyoutuber
のように私が想像できる最も近いものにはおそらく良い機会があると思います
それは
お嬢様です
が、彼はアイドルの
ようなものですが、
私は確かに
、
まだ満たされていない市場であるか、外国人のようにまだ満たされていないニッチのようなものであるという議論があると思います
ウェイトリフティングを教えているか
、日本語で面白いウェイトリフティングスキットが好きです日本
を教えるために英語に来てくださいと言ってください日本を教えるため
に長老のジョークが
英語に来て
ください
ちなみに、私は本当に感謝し
ています。
こんにちは、ドーガンは長い間ファンであり、私は
学んでいます。 約2年間学校に通っている日本人は
今、基本的な漢字で
話しましたが
、できるだけ多くの漢字を学ぶための最善の方法は、個々の漢字
を勉強するのではなく、
複数の漢字を持つ個々の単語を勉強することだと思います それらの中で
、ankiデッキのようにダウンロードし
てanki
srs app umの
ようになり、できるだけ多くの単語を覚えて覚えて
ください。 さやく
あなたは無意識のうちに
視力が最も意味があることを学び始めるでしょう、
それで私はそのアプローチ
が私にとって最もうまくいったものに最もよく働くと思いますそしてそれは
私がほとんどの人に
あなたが私のお気に入りのyoutuberキーであるよう
に勧めるものです すべて
のビデオ
に感謝します実際には彼女は本当に
本当に面白いとは思い
ませんそして
私があなたに言ったら私はすでに
youtuber
[音楽]の
ような革新的なオリジナルの
新鮮な小説のようなものです e kakume
tekisoii彼はそうではないと思ったのは
本当にあなたが知っているようなものでした。youtubeの世界の
ように新鮮なもののようなもの
でした。最先端は少し違い
ます。 すでに文化や技術の中にある特定のものの最も進んだ部分
ですが、
残心のニュアンスはイマーム
に似ていますが、それは非常に似ていますが、
わずかに異なります。残心はイマームナカタのようにオリジナルに似ていると思います。
革新的なものと最先端のものの違いは異なり
ますが、
私たち
がオリンピック
に賛成して1年以上ロックアウトされている留学生の状況を知っていますか？
ええ、私は状況を知っています、そして私は
本当に不幸な状況
だと思ってください。あなたのよう
な留学生全員に不利益を与えていると思い
ます。
明らかにyについて言われることがあります。
新しい人を国に入れることは知って
いますが、慎重に新しい人を国に
入れることについても言われる
ことがあります。
特に、日本に行くなどの
必要な予防措置を講じて
いる人にとっては、ロックダウンするかしないかということもあると
思います。
入会者以外の
人は2週間隔離して、すべてをやり
ます。少なくとも
、日本の大学のように、おそらくその場所が保証されている学生にとっては、うーん、うーん
、いいアイデアだと思い
ます。
[音楽]
[音楽
] マットマットは確かに
マットがまだここにあるかどうかはわかりませんが、
マット
は私よりもはるかに多いので
、どちらの言語でもあまり明確ではないので、ある程度英語でもやめなければなりません
が
会話の途中でたくさん立ち止まりますええと
こんにちは私はちょうど始めましたえ
えとええとスーパーチャットスポットをありがとう私
はここ数ヶ月日本語を学び始めたばかりです
主にワニカンジとイタルキのレッスンを使用します
どうすればいいですか
言葉を聞くのが上手に
なり、言語をマスターするためのより速いルート
はできるだけ多くの日本語を聞く
ので、ええマットは本当に良い点を作りました
ええと、
長いユーチューブのビデオを撮影すること
は私が英語を話すのが上手になるのを助けたと思います
これは本当に良い点だと思います。
おそらく英語と日本語の両方でこれを言ってみるべき
ですが、あなたがあなたの考えを明確に表現しなければならない場所にいることを強制されないのであれば、あなたの要求がなければ
面白く
て説得力のある方法で一瞬の通知
を実際に試してみると、
実際に
はほとんどの人が私
にとって一部の人にとってよく理解しているよりもはるかに難しい
です特に私にとっては非常に
困難でし
たが、あなたが次のようなことを始めた場合のように
このような生活をしたり
、面白いスクリプトのように書くのが好きなYouTube動画を作成したりするの
は、選択した単語の重要性について考える
必要があります
[M  usic]
[音楽]
申し訳ありませんが、妻にメッセージを送ってください。
ええと、
日本には精神障害のある大人のための統合サービスがあります。
統合
サービスはあります
かええ、日本は実際
にはかなりの数の
障害があると思います申し訳ありませんが、私は障害について考えていましたが、それは別の
精神的精神的精神障害
は一種の障害です
政府は
、障害のある人を雇う努力をし
ているが、それ以外の場合
は正常に機能している脳
を持っているので、
足の障害のような人のように、
車椅子に乗っているような人のように
、かなり良いイニシアチブがあります。 そのカテゴリーの
人々についての私の理解では
、私は
精神
障害のある大人についてあまりよくわかり
ません。申し訳ありませんが、それを与えることができないだけです。
よく知っ
ていることで、お詫び申し上げます。
[音楽]
外国人
は
um
[音楽]
とにかく
外国人に感謝
します。日本語の名前のピッチアクセントのようなものに関連するいくつかのルールについて話していました。
[音楽]
だからニック私はちょうど話し
ていました。あなたがチャットにどれくらいいたかわかりません。 でも、
実際にルールがあるのかと話していたのですが、英語で日
本語で説明したことを説明しようとして
います。名前が名前のようになっていることに基づいて、誰かの名
前のピッチアクセントを決定するのに役立つ日本語のルールが実際にあります。 それは私で終わります例えば、ああええと
終わる女の子の名前です
が、ニックネームで立ち止まってくれてありがとうええと、すぐに
あなたのことを話しますが、
とにかく
、女の子の名前である夏美なつみのような日本の名前でええと、女の子の名前である
まゆみ 同様に
両方
ともmで終わります
私で終わるeと女の子の名前は
ビートなので、夏目と同じように
、
ほとんどの場合フラット
で3つのモーラがあり
ます。日本語の2つのモーラの名前は
すべて2つすべてなので、例外です。 日本語でもっと名前があり
ます
ええあきみあけみはもう一つの本当に良い
例
です
ええとえええええええええええええええええななみそれはまた別の
良い名前
かもしれません
少なくとも3つのモーラな
ので、これらの名前はすべて、
別の良いものである
カスミです。
しかし、それの代わりに、
それが別の良いものでも
あり
ます。たとえば、私の代わりに、たとえばコルトのように終わった
場合、圧倒的な大多数の
場合
、それはええめぐみ
になります。
フラットである
ことはアクセントになるので、ナオミと
言えばフラットです
が、ナオコと言えばアクセントナオコです
が
、日本語の名前を取り巻くルールに完全に専念するレッスンが2、3回あります
ええと、
私が今説明した他の規則ええと、私が今説明した他の規則は
、
形容詞に由来する名前と形容詞に由来する名前に
はアクセントが
ありますが、動詞に由来する名前にはアクセントがない
ので、
は動詞から来ている
ので、単語を見るだけ
でヘブロンパターンで言われていることがわかります
が、えーと、先ほどの例を見
てみましょう。しずかが生まれた神です。
か
よしそうけいおしに由来する名前の
形容詞にアクセント
があります日本語のええとスクリプトにもう一つの本当に良いええと
名前がありました
h名前の高低アクセントは
私に1秒だけ与えます名前
の高低アクセントを決定してください
私は今スクリプトを開いています
ええとそうそうそうそれは別の良い
例のようです
のぞみあなたがのぞみ
と言う理由は、
のぞみが動詞に由来するから
です。たとえば、アキラという名前は、あの形容詞のアキラカ
アキラカに由来するので、アクセント付きの
アキラアキラと
呼ばれます。
あなたが学ぶことができる具体的なルールと
これは私が私のピッチアクセントシリーズで教えている
ことです私の名前イズミは
ファーストネームとラストネームイズミとして異なるピッチを
持っていますが、とにかく誰かのピッチ
を決定するために使用できる異なるルールがあります
名前が
聞こえなくても、
ええと、ドガン、元気ですか。私は
ただ、これは、私が
ハナについて話すようなものです。
ニック、あなたがまだここにいるかどうかはわかりません
が、今チャット中のニッキウムという男がいて
、彼はおそらく西洋人のために今まで聞いた中で最高の
日本語を持っ
ています。昨日彼についてツイートしました
2日前
、彼の日本語は素晴らしいと思います。彼の
発音は私のものよりも優れています。
彼の語彙は私のものよりも優れ
ています。彼は私よりも雄弁で
日本語の面ではるかに美しいです。 非常に高い
レベルで
私はあなたを励まします、あるいはあなたが
日本語を勉強しているだけでも、
ニックのチャンネルをチェックすることをお勧めします。
いいですね、彼と
彼に連絡を取りました。マットかもしれません。もう少し時間があれ
ば、ビデオを作ってみ
ます。今は少し忙しい
ので、アメリカの税金を申告します。
そんなことニック私は
ポートランド出身な
ので、関係を築けると思いますが、これがすべて終わったら、あなたとコラボレーションし
たいと思います。チャンネルを成長させるために、あなたが好きですが、
彼は 彼
は素晴らしい発音をしていて
、面白いチャンネルを手に入れました。妻は
、あなたが何年も前
に日本語で歌っていたテレビ番組のようなものを見たと
言っていました。 あなたはええ
マットもここにいます私
はあなたが話していたその男を知っています
私はずっと前に彼に会ったので
それでも彼の日本語は
素晴らしかった
です
これらのスパの
スーパーチャットに、私が逃したカップルがい
ました。コンテンツが楽しいのに素晴らしい愛であることに感謝します
が、有益
な問題は
ありません。私がやろうとしていることのようなもの
です。
ええと、
寄付のために非常に最善の方法は何ですか
より日常的な状況にデゴザルを追加する
ので、残念ながら
私はサインインが好きでなければなりません私はウェブブラウザで開いているのかわかりません
私がobs内でサインインしようとするとクラッシュするのではないかと心配してい
ますが、
みんなに勧めます ニック
のチャンネルをチェックしてくださいカタカナを
入力するだけで素晴らしいチャンネルができます
コメントを残したい場合は表示されるかニックになると
思いますおそらくあなたのチャンネルを見つけるための最良の方法のように
それを見ると表示されるはずです。2年目
も勉強を続けるように私に刺激を与えてくれてありがとう。
あなたのアドバイスなしではそこにたどり着くことができませんでした。
できるだけ多くの人
がニックのレベルに到達する必要があります
が、もっと多くの人にインスピレーションを与える前に、
ええと、ホッカイドではないお気に入りの県です
。 チャンネル私は
あなたがあなたのビデオで言ったように意味します あなたはおそらくあなたを何よりもレベルに到達させ
たものであり、
これはマットにとっても真実だと思います。
私も大変な
仕事です。
また、私はあなたの
日本語が私のものよりも明らかに優れているからです。
まるで
、あなたが何年にもわたってどれだけの仕事をしてきたかを尊重
しなければならないようなものです。だから、この男はあなたが知っているハッスルを尊重しなければならないような人のようです。
あなたのビデオは本当に
うーん
だったので、あなた自身の日本語を聞くこと
は何年にもわたって大いに役立ちました
[音楽]
あなたが子供の頃に一般的な演技のように音楽のバックグラウンド
を持っていたのは幸運
でした 勉強を
楽しんだええiii本当に勉強を
楽しんだええそれは
あなたが実際に勉強するのが好きなときに確かに役立つことです
がそれでも私は
あなたがクレイジーな量の仕事をしていることは明らかです
あなたが知っている人は、私
があなたに知ってもらいたい多くの仕事をして、彼らが可能な限り成長するのを見て
、
あなたもクールな男のように見える
ので、ええ、私は
um
[音楽]
yothis
[音楽 ]
私はそれらの
英語の字幕に取り組む
必要が
あると思いますええそうですiiあなたが
ええと
同じタイトルの英語版またはあなたがええと同じビデオをアップロードするのは何と言う価値があるかもしれません
そのビデオに
私は確かに多くの人々が
そのビデオから学ぶことができると思い
ますええとシアトルのuwからこんにちはちょっとしかしあなたはワシントンに行くのに十分賢いです
ええ私は知りません
[音楽]
方法 あなたは日本のアクセントを選び
ましたかええと、私はあなたが何を求めているのか完全にはわかりませんが、私はいつも意識的に
ひょうじんごを勉強しようとし
ました。
カーンサイベンを少し話すカンサを少し話す
ええと、きょうじんごは、日本の
音が断片化していて
、キノのようなことを言う
と、昨日のように言っているのか、機能のように言っているのかわからないかもしれません。
私はスパカイルに感謝します
umhidogan私は
アンキを通して勉強している新しい日本人学習者
です私は見つけることができる没入型コンテンツを楽しんでい
ますが、
量は
本、
音楽映画などの推奨を脅かしています私はチャンネルが大好きです
ええと
、日本語を学ぶのに最適な日本の映画
は
、法廷ドラマであり
、最初から最後まで対話に過ぎず、
若い俳優がいて、
年配の俳優がいて
、彼らは
丁寧な日本語でしか話し始めないからだといつも感じていました しかし、
映画が進むにつれて、彼ら
はよりリラックスした日本人のように他の日本人も話し始める
ので、それは日本人の良いスペクトルを持っているので、
それは古い映画なので
、映画の日本人はそれほど
多くのローンを持っていません ギドの
ような多くの人が好きではないのも好きです
その映画は誰かがタイプすることができ
ますそうそう誰かがこの
12種類の日本人または12種類の
日本人12を入力してください
でもそれはいつも
最高の映画
だと思っていたのですが[音楽]大丈夫ですからあなたを動かして
動かしてください av
tuberjesus100万人のチャンネル登録者がいますここで何をしているのか
よく動きます
プロットのような映画は非常に興味深いものであり
、映画を通してキャラクターがどのように変化するかを見るのはとても興味深いです
ええええそれは12人の
怒っている男性のようなものに基づいて
います プロ たぶん
15分くらいで
出発します。妻が私の昼食を作り終えたらすぐに出発します
が、ええと、ただ頭を上げて
ください。
ああ、妻がいることを自慢しているこの男を見てください
[音楽]
ええと、
アクセントはスペクトルまたは鼻音を使用してい
ます日本の音声学の説明
ええと、お金のカウンターの
名誉の名の発音方法
でも、
オートマチック
パート2は
本当に面白かったので、これをすばやく引き上げましょう。
動詞に関係なく動詞を取得し、
oを付けて、最後にoを付けると、
oになり、そのままになります。 最後まで高くて
、それから偶然の肉で
それが1つの良い例です
もう1つは別の
本当に良いルールが
ありました申し訳ありませんが今チャットを見てい
ません私に1秒与えて
くださいええと
[音楽]
ああ、私は取得しに行かなければならない 私のパッケージは申し訳ありません
が、動詞になった名詞の前に敬語が付いているとすぐに戻ってきます。
結果として得られる複合語
は、
アクセントがありますが、おやすみに
なります。他の例は
申し訳ありません。 時々人々は
有名人のアクセントや
あなたの声
が英語よりも日本語で少し深く聞こえる何かを模倣すること
があります私は言うのが難しいさまざまな
学派のよう
に私は多分少し高い声で話すことは
少し強調する ちょっと
ええと、ペイチェックでいい仕事をしてくれて、それは
私を助けてくれました。
あなたはそれらのルールを本当に素早く引き上げたノートにどのプログラムを使用しますか？
私は
アルフレッドを使用していますそれはマック専用です
かなり最近なので、
間違いなくアルフレッドをチェックしてください。それは、ゴッドセンドのような
ものです。1秒でごめんなさい。
出てきたみんなに感謝します私は
本当に素晴らしい時間を過ごしましたええと、
このストリームは私が絶対に
必要だったのです
ニックがまだ
ここにいるのかどうかわからないけど、マットを見ただけで
、ビートセイバーvチューバーも、
すみません、あなたの名前を思い出せません。
youtube
だから、やらなきゃいけないけど、ええと、私の
妻は日本人です
ええ、出てきたみんなのおかげであなたを動かしてください
私
はかなり近い将来に別のライブストリーム
をやりたいのです
が youtubeなので、もっと多くのライブストリーム
を見ることに興味があるなら
、私のtwitter
やtwitchに来るかもしれませんが、最近は少なくとも週に1回はtwitchでストリーミングしようとしていますが
、youtubeは
2か月に1回
くらいのようです。
とにかく行かなくちゃいけないけどみんなありがとう 帽子が入ってき
て、先ほど話した漢字の漢字が
、一般的なルールであり
、そのルールには例外があるので、そのルールの例外である警察官の
ように知っているので
、
注意してください
そのルールには例外があります。
とにかく私は始めました
が、また出てきたみんなに感謝します。
またすぐにみんなと話をします。
さようなら
ああ、スーパーチャットええと、すみません
、終了します。 ここでストリームしますが、
私の意見では漢字を勉強するための最良の方法は、私の意見
では漢字自体を勉強するのではなく、複数の漢字を含む個々の
単語で勉強して数百を勉強することです。
日本彼はこれについても
話します